you just made yourself a target right
yeah there's one guy there it's
relatively easy to defend against just
shoot him hi my name is evan wilson i'm
a professor at the u.s naval war college
and i'm an expert in 18th century naval
warfare today i'll be looking at naval
warfare scenes in movies and judging how
real they are
so if you're desperate and you you're
being chased by someone who you know is
stronger than you you would throw things
overboard if you're trying to speed up
but the thing that's really going to
light the ship is throwing the guns
overboard i mean that's the fastest way
to lighten it a 32-pound cannon or
something like that weighs 7 000 pounds
what they're throwing overboard is like
a single cannonball isn't gonna make any
difference in the speedier ship
this is a maneuver that's called club
hauling drop an anchor off the side in
an attempt to rapidly turn the ship in
another direction it did happen but you
did it in an emergency when you were
trying to extricate your ship from a
very dangerous situation
rather than as a
tactic in battle usually you could
surprise a black pearl but it's going to
take
many minutes for this maneuver to happen
i mean it is a surprise because it's
really dumb
so that's chain shot
that's a real thing it's either an
anti-personnel thing because it's gonna
spin
or you fire it at the rigging in the
hopes of cutting ropes as it spins
through i'd be surprised if you have a
one-shot
thing that brings the mass down like
that a good naval gun crew that's got a
lot of men on it
can load and fire a cannon in a minute
but you probably couldn't sustain that
for very long it looks like there are
like eight people on the ship like i
said so
you know they could fire one
gun but not all of them you need a lot
of men
it's a great way to make yourself a
target probably much more likely to end
up in between the ships which is a great
way to get crushed to death it's very
cinematic it's very evocative and it
looks like sort of a tarzan-s thing i
get that but
you're asking for trouble and i think
when people are firing at you
doing that is
not smart
one of the things you don't see here is
that it's actually really hard to keep
two ships right next to each other we
saw these ships moving in opposite
directions um something would have
needed to have happened to keep them
near each other right now this is just
uh very conveniently i guess they've
anchored next to each other so that they
can duke it out like in the pirates
universe this is a 10 out of 10. it's
about as accurate as they ever get um in
reality it's like a i don't know 4 out
of 10.
[Music]
they showed a couple shots there of the
crowded deck of what we know is a
british frigate that's much more
accurate i mean these ships are going to
be crawling with men
so that's a pretty
risky strategy to try to knock down the
main mast of the of the enemy ship
because mass are hard to hit but firing
into the rigging was a real tactic
because the master held up by the
rigging so the reason you'd want to
knock the enemy mass down is to disable
his ship and then he couldn't chase you
anymore and then you could just leave
often the british practiced firing hard
and low into enemy hulls into the enemy
ship with the idea of killing men not to
sink the ship
it's really actually it's really hard to
sink a wooden ship wood floats instead
what you're doing is you're trying to
kill the crew the knock-on effect of
that is that you can either board them
and take them or they'll be so disabled
and so damaged that they will surrender
to you and then you can go take
possession
[Music]
those are ropes that they're throwing
over to try to get the ships to stay
together to solve that problem of the
ships moving apart it's really hard to
get two ships to actually get close
enough together to board
ships have something called a tumble
home the hoe is shaped so that the sides
aren't straight up and down the sides
actually turn in a little bit which
means that when two ships are next to
each other they both have
tumble homes that are going this way
which means it's across from one deck to
the other is actually a long way the
challenge of actually getting two ships
next to each other to board them is is
real they do a good job in this movie of
showing you that there are different
ways that you can go about doing it i
mean they got almost everything right
this is a 10 out of 10.
that's supposed to be sort of the bow
sprit that's the
mass that sticks out the front of the
ship
that's really essential to hold up most
of the rigging of a ship if you were to
put elaborate metal claws on the front
of it you'd first of all probably not be
able to sail the ship very well secondly
be very heavy on the front of your ship
and cause your ship to go like this you
can run your ship into the other ship
and then board it from there but you do
that by just clambering over your own
bow sprit you don't do it by like having
staging an elaborate entrance in which
once again just like with the tarzan
rope thing you just made yourself a
target right i mean they stand there
shocked that it's euron but like just
shoot him
flaming arrows
i would say no that's not something that
would work mainly because to make a
flaming arrow work you probably have to
light it on your own ship and fire is by
far the biggest threat to ships would
canvas pitch tar like this stuff is
really flammable firing flaming arrows
at someone else's ship is much more
likely to set your own ship on fire than
to set the other guys ship on fire the
fact that they correctly identify that
one of the greatest fears for a fleet
would be
fire
and that would be the thing that would
make euron scary i think is
is accurate
the two ships are about to be on fire
that would be very bad that would be
catastrophic you would be much more
concerned about the fire than about
whatever the enemy is doing would you
keep fighting in a storm the answer is
it would affect tactics but it wouldn't
necessarily keep you from fighting
there's a famous example of
two
british frigates chasing a much larger
friendship in 1797 and normally the two
if if the weather had been calm the two
frigates probably would have run away
from the bigger friendship but because
the storm was so bad the french ship
couldn't open its lower gun ports
because the water would have come in
too low right so the friendship was
basically half as powerful as it would
have been
i don't feel like i need to explain that
but um i can if you want what's the name
of the carnival ride that's what they
clearly saw that at a carnival and they
were like
let's make that happen
the guy swings like tarzan comes around
fires a gun and then gets shot in the
face because of course he would because
you see a guy swinging like i'm gonna
shoot you now boarding is risky right
when you board another ship you need to
be pretty confident that you are
superior to the enemy that you're
boarding because if you
board an enemy ship and it goes poorly
then you might lose your own ship
whereas if you hadn't bothered to board
them in the first place you probably
wouldn't get captured and you'd be much
more likely to just obliterate them at a
distance and then once they surrender
take over the ship and say well that was
better a lot of movies have boarding in
them because it's very cinematic and
it's a lot more interesting than
watching two ships just fired each other
for a long time that's a one ward c is
not a carnival ride
that's just
look at the way that the wind is blowing
the sails of the british ship
from behind and the sales dealership
from that direction i mean that's a
really good illustration of the wind
doesn't work like that the wind is uh
has been disengaged from this scene
so that these ships can turn however
they like a lot of the times in the
asian sail coaster we've been seeing you
know they're turning the ship's wheel
kind of like you're just sort of
spinning it like i was gonna throw this
way and spin it usually it took two guys
it would take two people there to you
know really work the wheel because
you're turning a really large piece of
wood in water so you turn the wheel and
that turns
that moves ropes that are connected to
the tiller that are connected to the
rudder and the rudder does steer the
ship so you you do need to spin the
wheel
but uh often these ships are turning on
a dime with nothing happening in the
sails and you're expected to believe
that that's how it worked so you would
turn the wheel to do that but you'd also
do a thousand other things and the wind
would have to be just right in the right
place and it would take a while
these ships are
passing each other very quickly i mean
the combined speed there is like i don't
know 15 miles an hour the number of
seconds you'd probably have in which
these other the enemy ship was in just
the right position
to fire on it would be
very few and so you'd end up with them
just you know you do a little bit of
damage and then the ship would just sail
on you could double up on an enemy ship
like that and there are famous examples
of it at the battle of the nile in 1798
the british do this to the french it's a
great way to do a lot of damage because
it forces the enemy to fire on both
sides to figure out which way you know
you know to concentrate
they do a good job actually here of
showing the splinters and the the one
realistic thing about this clip is that
the air gets filled with splinters and
splinters were the real danger that was
what hurts you you're very unlikely to
be hit by an actual cannonball it
happened of course but the splinters are
the k are the thing here like these
things are coming at uh you know bullet
speeds there are famous examples of
ships exploding um
they're rare but certainly they did
happen the magazine is where you store
the powder if the magazine
catches fire then you'd see a major
explosion like an iron cannon cannonball
doesn't bring with it any
explosive power there's nothing that
goes boom there it's just a solid iron
ball
so it's unlikely that an enemy shot is
going to cause a magazine to explode
it's not something you could really aim
for it's much more likely that some fire
got started on board that then spread to
the magazine because remember all the
guns on that ship need sparks in order
to ignite the powder to get them to fire
so there's a lot of
flames in and around powder on board a
ship and if something goes wrong you
could have that happen
wood floats
right that's wood doesn't take a nose
dive and be like well i'm done floating
now you know see ya there'd be wreckage
everywhere and all that wreckage would
float you'd end up with water coming in
the hole and it would sink slowly over
time certainly not after a single pass
from two
uh ships sailing in the opposite
direction on a magical wind so this clip
is a two mainly because of the splinters
and ships did explode but all the
sailing stuff is ludicrous
yeah i don't know what to say about that
what happens when a ship goes downhill i
don't know
i'd be much more concerned about the
wave
and the curvature of the earth there
than the enemy ships but that's a
fantasy element we can leave aside
[Music]
rowing a ship using human
power
is pretty inefficient the way to get
your ship
going fast enough to do any damage with
a ram means that the rest of the ship
needs to be pretty light and you need a
lot of rowers they've done some uh
testing on this the answer is an
untrained crew could get a triumph
growing maybe nine knots which
is like a jog it's like eight miles an
hour right so
yeah it's not that fast the way that
they're sort of moving relatively slowly
as they approach the ship is yeah sure
and then it's like sort of accelerated
at the end and went and then the ship
bent you could probably poke a hole in
the guy's ship if you really were gonna
try to ram the guy and you would aim for
the middle of the other guy's ship
because that probably would be the
weakest part but you're unlikely to sink
him because again wood floats it's
really hard to sink ships what you're
more likely to do is just damage him
enough that you can board him but what
doesn't work in this clip is that the
vessels that you would expect to see
here are fair weather ships right so
galleys triremes that sort of thing
these are not all weather vessels that
are going to handle a big sea these
ships would be mainly struggling to
survive rather than able to fight much
maybe it's a five yeah they had triremes
they fought like this sort
the
division of the pirate ship into small
ships to send them out to attack the
small ship doesn't make a ton of sense
to me you'd use the small boats on your
big
ship
to tow you places in a flat calm
sometimes if it were an emergency but
otherwise the little boats that you've
got are not going to help do much
a smaller maneuverable ship could
theoretically run away from big ships in
the right conditions
the speed of a ship depends on about a
thousand different factors you're going
to deal with
the wind direction the wind speed which
direction the ship is trying to go
relative to the wind moana and maui are
going to be more maneuverable they're
going to be able to sort of change
direction very quickly i think for
realism you know it's a
six i mean they're coconut pirates so
let's not get too carried away
so now's probably a good time to talk
about range
the guns that they're firing in this
period are not usually rifled right so
they have smooth bore barrels which
means that
the cannonball is slightly smaller than
the barrel
which means that as it fires down the
barrel it's got windage so it can bounce
around the barrel as it goes and then it
goes off there so they're not
particularly accurate right think of a
musket as opposed to a rifle that said
they can throw a ball really far so the
muzzle velocity of a 32-pound cannon
here is like
1500 feet per second or i think mach 1.3
it's going faster than the speed of
sound
and so
you could hit something
at maybe a mile whether you could hit
what you were aiming at at a mile
less clear but at a mile you could
probably if you got the pitch just right
and you hit it on the roll you could get
a ball to go that far unlike most movies
that immediately shrink the battlefield
down to right next to each other it does
a good job of sort of showing that yeah
you could actually open up at a pretty
good range and expect maybe to hit
something ideally you want to be within
a quarter of a mile
you'd only do that in
very short ranges
ships are constantly moving right and
they're moving faster than you can swim
so the idea that you would be able to
risk
swimming across to an enemy ship
and then when you board it there'd be
enough of you
to actually do something with it is very
unlikely in a fleet battle like this
it's very rare what they did at
trafalgar this lieutenant swam across to
a french ship and then managed to get
ropes tossed to him so that they could
grapple the ships together again to
board it but it's within range of
someone to be able to throw a rope not
like a mile or whatever the distance is
here would you do it at that range no
would you open up guns at that range
that's it looks pretty far to me but
it's hard to judge distances here so
i'll say seven
that weird funnel of ships was strange
there are a lot of collisions that are
about to happen in that fleet right
there so you wouldn't get that close to
each other but they're basically trying
to form a line of battle forming a line
of battle was a technique developed in
the middle of the 17th century in the
1650s roughly
and
it was a defensive technique so
you form ships in a line of battle one
after the other lined up like this
remember that ship's guns the the most
powerful ones fire sideways
but ships sail forward right do you wind
up all the ships in your fleet one after
the other like this in a line so that
the weakest part of every ship the bow
and the stern is facing a friend
the most dangerous part is facing the
bad guy you form a really effective
defensive barrier that means that it's
very difficult for the enemy to do
anything to you because you can
keep them at bay with your massive
powerful guns all lined up and that's
called the line of battle
and it basically is the major fleet
tactic for the next 150 years if you had
a solid line of battle that wouldn't get
broken then chances are you weren't
going to lose the battle
that gun sort of gently rolled back
when it fired
like that's not nearly violent enough
at seven thousand pounds moving
backwards ten to eleven feet you
wouldn't really even see it it would be
so fast because the thing that's going
out the front is going out at mach 1.3
now that put a huge amount of stress on
the ship's side because it meant that
the bolts that held into the ship's side
had 16 tons of force pulling them that
way every time you fire the gun so one
of the things that they learn over time
is don't fire every single gun on the
ship at the same time do a rolling
broadside so that you don't exert 16
tons of power on every single bracket on
every single side of your ship so bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang not
kaboom right it wouldn't necessarily
tear the ship to pieces but it certainly
put more stress on it than it would if
you sort of staggered the firing a
little bit to fire these cannons put the
uh slow match on the touch hole well all
that's doing is igniting a stream of
powder a fuse that's going to go down
the touch hole into the actual charge
and then sometime in the next two or
three seconds
the cannon is going to fire but i can't
exactly predict it which again makes
aiming really hard because the ship is
moving in all sorts of directions right
it's going forward it's going uh you
know pitching and rolling and yawing and
all these other dimensions they do a
good job of actually showing slow match
in this clip but they don't
it you know the guns don't recoil fast
enough and there's not enough sort of
uncertainty about it this is probably an
eight you don't normally see lines of
battle in movies and so credit where
credit's due if you take nothing else
away from this show right wood floats if
you enjoy this video click above to
watch another one